all right Rachel from patreon says as a
minimalist my family knows not to buy me
physical gifts and instead buy me
experiences or gift cards I just
imagined Attell she says it's her family
Rachel why you so mean to your family
anyway yes going in saw the voice in my
head talking to people in my life
well here's Rachel's real voice however
I always feel guilty buying someone else
a physical gift even if they're not a
minimalist this is tricky because gift
cards can feel inauthentic they
certainly can and there are other events
such as bright or baby showers where a
physical gift is expected any tips on
this yeah Rachel stop worrying about how
you feel about the gift and worry more
about how the person you're giving the
gift to feels because that's what really
matters I mean whether you're a
minimalist or not like if Mariah wanted
let's go back to the Bose speakers yeah
I really wanted this Bose speaker and
it's like it's really gonna add a bunch
of value to her life I'm not gonna be
like sorry Mariah
we're minimalists I don't buy physical
gifts what's your next preference oh you
can afford it right oh yeah yeah
absolutely if you're like I want a
brand-new Lex what to feel guilty but to
feel guilty about buying a physical gift
that is that's Rachel's preference
because she doesn't like physical gifts
and as a minimalist you'd like to buy
physical items but when you're doing
something for somebody else you've got
to leave your preference out of it right
I mean if I said to you Josh you know
what I really do want a birthday present
this year and I want it to be you know
gay porn like I want you to buy me a
bunch of gay porn but but my point is is
like that's not your preference it
doesn't matter what your preferences
mean if you if you legitimately went to
music somehow for some reason against my
values I'm sure the different yeah like
it's not so it would be a right I'm just
trying to think of something extreme
work so what I'm getting you for your
birthday here's what I'll add to that
Ryan I think all so what you're saying
is don't batter people with your beliefs
yeah and as long as your preferences
yeah right and as we talked about during
the minimal episode like the your
beliefs
are not the same thing as your values I
don't want you to compromise your values
yeah but your beliefs just get you down
that path
yeah maybe a better example is is a bag
of onions there you go you hate onions
yeah
but I'm like I love onions right I want
two bags of onions for my birthday
mm-hmm and if you were like oh no Ryan
see I don't like buying onions so I
can't get you that next like that is
that's your you're not showing love and
respect and support at that point
you